hello there welcome if you are watching
this it is because you are under 35 and
our main story this week was about
homeowners association so we thought
we'd make a special substitute story
just for you as you will never be able
to afford a house never absolutely never
it will not happen so in lie of you
having a home that is also an investment
which again won't happen for you we have
made this segment that Taps into
something for which you and your age
cohorts may have deep deep Nostalgia and
it concerns this how many times can you
go Chuck chees before you've done
everything there is to do that's a very
good question Pizza count the tunnel
jump in the
maret right over there Chuck E cheese
where kid be a yes chuckecheese with the
seminal motto where a kid can be a kid
as opposed to where a kid can see a dead
body in the parking lot which I believe
is the slogan for Applebees and it is
not untrue also if you are anything like
me you saw that ad and found yourself
wondering who the is the old guy at
the end there I've got about a thousand
questions about incoherent gandal he
looks like he just escaped from jumangi
and he sounds like he just free Bas tryp
ofan it is it is hard to make out what
he's saying there but after my 50th
viewing I think I finally figured out
what's going on you see they begin the
ad by asking how many times can you go
to Chuck e- cheeses before you've done
everything that there is to do and they
end it with him pointing across the
arcade as he says I started right over
here implying that he's been going to
Chuck-E-Cheese for a conservative 100
years essentially the message of the ad
is come to Chuck-E-Cheese we guarantee
you will die here now if you were a
child or a parent anytime in the last
four decades you've undoubtedly been to
a Chuck-E-Cheese at least once they're
the original pizza and Arcade restaurant
made famous by their animatronic band
which played hits like
this got it together we got it we got it
together with you we got it together
forever now that we're together things
couldn't be better we got
Le yes munches make believe ban
shreds
and and I will introduce you to the
whole band later on but real quick I
simply love the fact that this purple
monstrosity is named munch I adore any
creature named after a colloquialism for
a certain sex act and I've got to say
the name does fit that is the face of a
deep sea Explorer you can just tell per
alicious never stops diving his treasure
is your pleasure he's a reverse DJ khed
if you will but as an adult you probably
only hear hear about the restaurant
whenever it gets bad pressed like the
fact that it was recently discovered
that some chuck-e-cheese's animatronics
still run on floppy discs or when the
company felt forced to put out a
statement swearing that it wasn't
recycling pizza slices although when
you're issuing a statement denying that
you have already lost the argument and
perhaps the most notable way that
Chuck-E-Cheese can show up on the news
these days is this some kidney parties
have turned into Battlegrounds and it's
the adults that are behaving badly we
have several injured people here at
Chucky Cheese yeah we are on our way
there there's a fight that broke out we
have people fighting punch in I need a
cop I
need wow a 911 call from a Chuck E
cheese should not sound the same as one
made after any Philadelphia sporting
event but the fact is adults do seem to
love to fight at Chuck-E-Cheese
viciously and often just search
Chuck-E-Cheese fight on Google and you
will unlock hours of content as well as
find articles like this one from 2008
about how just one Chuck-E-Cheese in
Wisconsin had called police to break up
12 fights in just two years in the
biggest fight seven officers arrived and
found 40 people knocking over chairs and
yelling in front of the restaurant's
music stage where a robotic singing
chicken and the chained namesake Mouse
perform with one local city official
quoted to saying what parent is going to
take their kids to a place where there
is alcohol and pistols being brandished
it was like something out of a quain in
Tarantino fil and that sounds about
right doesn't it especially because if I
had to take a guest those fights much
like a Tarantino film included a bunch
of white people saying they really
shouldn't be now why does this happen so
much why so much anger darkness and
viciousness rearing its head in the
brightly colored well-lit fun house
where it's been promised that a kid can
be a kid and you might be thinking well
John it's stressful to manage a group of
children and there is booze that is why
fight start but no no I believe it's
much deeper than that I believe that
there is a rot at the heart of
chuckecheese well I don't have a
definitive answer I do have a
tantalizing Theory and I'll be honest
when we started writing something about
Chuck-E-Cheese for you we were thinking
this will be five six minutes tops but
the more we looked into it the more
fascinated we got and this officially
got out of hand so I'm going to be
talking about Chuck-E-Cheese for and I'm
not kidding about this the next 2 5
minutes you can stop watching this at
any time if you like but this studio
audience cannot leave and abandoning
them feels like a pretty shitty thing
for you to do so let's start at the very
beginning it was the spring of
1977 Woody Allen had the number one
movie in the country the Son of Sam was
terrorizing New York and on May 17th the
first Chuck-E-Cheese opened in San Jose
California the restaurant arcade was the
brainchild of Nolan bushnel co-founder
of Atari you know the company who made
classic games like Space Race asteroids
pong pong doubles super pong pin pong
hockey pong super pong 10 Ultra pong
Ultra pong doubles and quadr pong every
single one of those is Real by the way
Bon was looking for a way to make money
off his game's usage in arcades and add
entertainment to meal time something
that he once described as fundamental to
The Human Experience because in
discussing the invention of
Chuck-E-Cheese he once said and I quote
throughout history there was a
celebration and the celebration had food
drink and games without exception
whether you were talking about the
summer solstice with primitive man to
the circuses in Rome there was always an
entertainment element I always felt that
was something that was lacking in
restaurants I wanted to add a dimension
of fun to the act of having a meal and
this feels like a pretty good time to
remind you that in the 1970s literally
everyone was on
drugs also if you're thinking the
Primitive summer solstice circuses in
Rome those both sound very violent and
sexual yes exactly we will get to that
remember this moment because it will be
important later the point is the
Chuck-E-Cheese was a response to the
needs of the Primal ID of humanity check
that super ego at the door as for The
Animal theme bushnel claims that his
decision to include talking animals was
inspired by his trip to Disneyland's
Tiki Room which in a way makes sense
doesn't it Chuck e- cheek is kind of
like Mickey Mouse butter rat but
interestingly that's not initially what
bushnel was going for with the character
originally Bushnell planned to name the
restaurant coyote pizza so he ordered
what he thought was a coyote costume for
his lead animatronic it turned out to be
a rat and Bushnell decided to run with
it first he thought of changing the
restaurant's name to Rick rat's pizza
but his team convinced him that having
rat in a restaurant's name wasn't the
best idea so they agreed on calling the
mascot Chuck Chuck E cheese was
originally almost more geared towards
adults he smoked a cigar he had a Jersey
accent it was kind of like an adult
night out like happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you you get it that's
true that is true the original
Chuck-E-Cheese was supposed to be a
coyote and once a rat was actually a bit
of a saucy Jersey in fact here
was one of the original animatronic
shows from
1979 by now it's probably no surprise to
any Bonnie we got a birthday number
coming up here well it's a surprise to
me I didn't even get a present me
neither Big C that's cuz it's not your
bir thing n with oh oh
yeah jeez folks I got to tell you it's a
tough way to make a living sitting in up
here plugged in at the same computer as
that fruit cake dog anyway anyway listen
let's find out which table is having a
birthday party yeah chuckecheese was
basically an insult comic he was mean he
was dangerous it felt like at any moment
he was about to put his cigar out on a
child's arm he was Joan Rivers meets Don
Rickles meets every uncle on the Jersey
Shore every birthday party probably
started with the delivery of a pizza and
ended with Chuck mercilessly destroying
a 5-year-old and the actor was filled
out by other characters like the
aforementioned Mr Munch a Perma hungry
husky alien from planet purple who
bushnel said was kind of our Cookie
Monster then there was Jasper T JS the
Southern Cowboy dog who when first
introduced was flanked by Confederate
flags and who buo later described by
saying the hound dog was stupid as
then there was Dolly dimples a seductive
hippo torch singer that would flirt with
patrons for a quarter as the first
president of the company Gan Landrum
later said every time she hit a high
note her boobs went up and down her
boobs went up and down when she hit her
high note and then the kids were
enamored with this and I said said oh my
god what have I done here and I can
actually answer that for you cuz it's
very simple you turned one of the
world's deadliest animals into a
headline performer at your casino and
titty bar for children that's what you
did also do you have any idea how
astronomically horny you have to be to
build mechanical dancing breasts for an
animatronic hippo it takes an
otherworldly horniness to even pitch
something like that in a business
meeting probably multiple meetings by
the way because I know it was a
different ER but surely that wasn't an
immediate yes from everyone around the
table at some point you had to say you
know what I want to Circle back to my
previous point about the hippo breasts
if that's okay and once it was okay you
had to relay that level of horny to a
team of Engineers other human beings you
gave them notes like I think we can get
more movement here don't you it's
Madness and I love it so look
it's clear from the start the
Chuck-E-Cheese was pulling from a lot of
inspirations Disney Sesame Street and
porn and they augmented all of this with
a costumed character of Charles
entertainment cheese who would walk
around the restaurant and as we now know
this concept was a smash hit people
absolutely loved the shitalking rat and
his boundary pushing Antics by 1980
they' added dozens of stores even a few
internationally and began franchising
the problem was pretty soon their
success attracted imitators there was
Captain Andy's Rivertown restaurant
there was text Critters Pizza Jamboree
major Magic's Allstar Pizza review
gadgets giggle bees and one called Pizza
Planet which had a truly horrifying
mascot now you can celebrate your
birthday with Pepe Rooney and Sylvester
Stallion at the Pizza Planet no no no no
no no no no no no I hate that so much I
hate everything about Dollar Store Kung
Fu Panda here I swore to myself I would
go to my grave never knowing what it
would look like if a panda bear
Michael Myers and that promise has has
now been fundamentally
broken but chuck-e-cheese's big rifle
was a chain called showz pizza place and
at this point in the story we are
meeting our antagonist and as in so many
great myths the antagonist actually
started out as an ally chuck-e-cheese's
success caught the attention of
businessman Robert Brock and he signed
on to franchise more than 200 locations
but that same year Brock ended up
canceling the deal finding an engineer
for animatronics and launching a family
restaurant chain of his own he called it
chiz Pizza the concept was pretty much
the same it was different characters but
the same kind of like Pizza arcade games
there was definitely a rivalry between
the two at the time and chiz had
arguably better animatronics Chuck and
his friends were limited to frames on
the wall chiz had an entire band called
Rocka fire explosion made of full body
characters now that is a pretty clear
Advantage isn't it the Chuck-E-Cheese
characters were trapped on the wall like
dead-eyed furry Hogwarts portrait so if
you wanted your children to have
three-dimensional fully articulated
nightmares Showbiz was really the only
place for you to go The Rocker fire
explosion was the result of a
collaboration between Robert Brock and
engineer Aaron fecta they basically took
Nolan Bushnell's idea for an animatronic
band and they near perfected it and they
made other adjustments to get an edge
over Chuck-E-Cheese too including a room
where moms could go to watch soap operas
while the kids play likely a big step up
from the treat the mom's got a Chuck e-
Cheese which I'm pretty sure involved
Chuck calling them Toots and whistling
as they bent over the ski Bard machine
come on it's my
boy showz pizza was a big hit and
unfortunately things got bad for our
cranky rat Chuck-E-Cheese sued shiz
Pizza resulting in a 2-year legal battle
that they eventually won but then came
the video game industry crash of 1983
and arcades were hit hard Chuck-E-Cheese
saw its Revenue plummet to the point
where they lost $15 million just that
year and like the dumbest person in your
family playing Monopoly Chuck-E-Cheese
declared bankruptcy Showbiz Peter
however was somehow able to weather the
storm and in a cataclysmic move that
would forever Change the World As We
Know It shiz snaps up its competitor
that's right shiz Peter snatched the rat
the copycat bought the original I will
hold for gasps
now
in
1985 the shiz and Chuck-E-Cheese merger
was completed but here is an unexpected
twist because it soon turns out the new
company could no longer use the rocker
fire explosion because Aaron fecta their
creator had parted ways with the company
but still owned the rights and declined
to hand them over to the newly merged
company essentially killing his own
Creations music career with the rocker
Fire characters now off the table the
new chain made the best of a bad
situation and started to retrofits the
animatronics to convert them to
Chuck-E-Cheese characters even putting
out this horrifying video for franchises
to understand exactly how to strip the
robots down now quick side note here
there are still massive rocker fire
explosion fans out there who've
collected and carefully restored the old
original animatronics a while back one
fan even went viral by programming his
private collection to sing current radio
hits like and this is real ushers loving
this club looking in your eyes while you
on the other side and nothing shy I got
a thing for you yeah do
it I can tell the way looking at me
[Music]
go are you not entertained are you not
entertained I have no notes I have
nothing to say about that other than how
great it is they should play the next
inauguration whoever it is for and look
I would be remiss if I didn't show you
how they handled that song's rap break
because however you think they did it
it's
better tra you got tra set you free
sexually mentally physically emotionally
be like your medicine you take every me
it's
going it's perfect there are not
many songs dirtier than Love in This
Club and it's frankly astonishing that
the perfect presentation of it is
through these wildly wholesome
animatronic characters and at this point
I actually have a quick side note to the
side note that we are already on because
the Resurgence in interest in the rock
of fire explosion about a decade ago
resulted in the band being recruited to
perform with CEO Green in the midst of
of his legal troubles live in Las Vegas
in 2013 we do have a clip from the
performance and one part in particular
doesn't hold up
[Music]
great sexual
harassment I
mean I
mean come
on Mr policeman I gave you all the clues
now now back to Chuck-E-Cheese the new
animatronics expanded the range of what
the band could do including the addition
of a redesigned Helen Henny the chicken
songstress who added a lot of class to
the ACT Helen how did you get started in
Show Business well there's a flock of
performers in my family my folks worked
in Beville doing a trampoline act there
I am but you mean you never heard of the
spring chicken oh no oh my come on babe
why don't we paint the
town and all that J come on that there
is a star just look at mother darling
face beat body snatched hair te so much
it in therapy as we speak that is a
mother clucking lip syn assassin right
there and then on the drums there was
pasquali who I can only describe as
illegally Italian it pasquali pasali the
chef here and I'm keeping time I provide
the Rhythm while we sing the RH be the
first to tell you that I'm quite a ham
everyone can see the great comedian I
am I I do hope that I'm not perpetuating
the same thing that I'm condemning when
I say now that's a spicy hate to
[Applause]
climb by the mid 1990s Chuck E and the
Gang were in their absolute prime
producing full-fledged music videos
educational content and sketch shows to
be played in stores in 1999 they even
made a featurelength film titled
chuckecheese in the Galaxy 5000 the
basic plot is this a child named Charlie
rocket needs $50,000 to fix his aunt and
uncle's tractor and the only people who
can help are Chuck and the Gang now why
is the maintenance of vital farm
equipment a child's responsibility it is
never made clear but the mascot sign up
for an Intergalactic race the titular
Galaxy 5000 to win the prize money it
isn't absolutely wild hour of film
history but here is just a taste of the
tone I'm Chucky and this is my navigator
Jasper hi I'm astred I think Racers are
so fascinating so you'll meet me at the
soda shop after the race
tomorrow you
bet see
[Music]
you wait Chucky you slide dog yep yep
they're all sexually attracted to human
women that is Cannon and you'd think
they'd keep it in their pants while a
literal child is with them but no they
are honking if they are horny they are
engaging in yeah what's the term CEO
sexual harassment that's it that's it I
knew you'd know needless to say at this
point Chuck-E-Cheese was on top of the
world but the good times never stay good
do they friends by the 2010s sales were
down and their cultural cache was drying
up so in 2012 the company went looking
for new direction to breathe some life
into the brand and the one that they
took was absolutely outrageous no longer
was Chuck E the wise cracking rat of the
70s and 80s or indeed the cat calling
smooth talker of the '90s and 2000s now
he was according to the company not a
rat at all he was a mouse with a never
before heard backstory that they
published into a full book the new
origin story goes that Chuck-E-Cheese
grew up in an orphanage named wait for
it St marinaras and quote because Chuck
E was an orphan no one knew when his
birthday was so he never had a birthday
party of his own this made Chuck E sad
so after winning $50 in a pong
tournament good cross branding by the
way he runs away to New York City where
he sleeps above the kitchen in a
pizzeria he's then discovered by a
friendly Italian chef named pasquali who
hears Chucky sing and declares a mouse
that can sing my restaurant is saved I'm
I going to make you a
star all the is to say Chuck-E-Cheese
was now a far cry away from the cigar
smoking shitalking rap that started it
all then in 2017 in a devastating blow
the company made this terrible decision
chuckecheese restaurants are disbanding
the classic animatronic band restaurant
simply says the taste of people have
changed over 40 years so the kids these
days they're not really interested in
the robot troop oh really they're not
interested in the robotss are they well
if that is true then kids these
days I don't typically hop into the
generation Wars because I've got a Gen X
birth certificate and a boomer body but
if gen Z or whatever the comes next
with the cause of all this they can burn
in the fires of eternal hell but sadly
it is true the animatronics started
getting phased out which is already
brutal enough but apparently when a
store gets rid of them or closes a
company policy requires them to destroy
chuck-e-cheese's head and other branded
items something that a local newspaper
reporter once captured on video it's
moving day for Chuck E cheese this is
Lorraine Swanson Al on patch and we're
smashing up the Chucky
head it's
symbolic I mean I guess I guess it's
symbolic they're smashing a
Chuck-E-Cheese head while a
Chuck-E-Cheese store goes out of
business it's not exactly subtext is it
to the extent that there is symbolism
there it's from the Darren AR an oi
School of subtlety and hints the point
is the company hit a major speed bump in
the mid 2010s and the pandemic just made
things worse and in a sign of just how
desperate they were to stay afloat the
company wound up doing this all right
listen to this a Reddit customer a
Reddit user I should say in Philadelphia
thought that she was supporting a local
pizza business when she ordered from
pascali's pizza but when her food
arrived it looked familiar she texted at
GrubHub uh the driver to say hey just
curious was this food from
Chuck-E-Cheese
turns out the chain is operating a
restaurant under a different name
pascali's pizza and wings what the
chuck-e
cheese you can't just change your name
and pretend to be something else that's
for rap artists looking to mix it up and
companies that did one too many
genocides look look I know I've been
talking about Chuck-E-Cheese for longer
than anyone thought was humanly possible
but this actually brings me to my point
here Chuck-E-Cheese has completely lost
the plot remember when I said was
working up to a theory this is that
moment right now my theory is
Chuck-E-Cheese was a brand founded on
Darkness there was inherent meanness a
viciousness a danger embedded in the
company from the jump it was modeled on
Solstice celebrations and Roman circuses
its tone was left of center and in a
ditch Chuck-E-Cheese was an
kids consent that they craved it
they liked being
neged and the parents appreciated kids
entertainment with some to it moms were
horny for the taboo attracted to the
danger and dads love to watch the
heaving bosom of an oversexed
animatronic hippo hell even Nolan
bushnel himself once spoke about
Chuck-E-Cheese at a professional Tech
talk like this you can't
imagine the weird things that people do
from inside of a Chuck-E-Cheese
costume the other thing that you don't
know is the weird weird things that
employees do in the Chuck-E-Cheese
changing room
closet locked door small space anyway um
think about that I'm pretty sure the
founder of chuckecheese just admitted
that people in the costume closet
and jerk it in the mascot suit that is
the guy responsible for your childhood
memories I bet when I made that joke
earlier about Mr Munch being named
explicitly after conalingus you thought
that I was reaching a bit you're not so
sure about that now are you but the
point here
is Nolan bushel was a weirdo who made a
boundary pushing Pizza Saloon that
people went cuckoo over and with every
sanitized Rebrand with every attempt of
making Chuck-E-Cheese the target of
sympathy instead of disgust the more the
customers absorb the rage that once
belonged solely to Chuck and now the
balance is all out of whack when Chuck
Cheese was off-kilter you as a customer
were free to relax but now that the rat
is a brain dead singing birthday orphan
with no discernible personality who
clearly doesn't Intergalactic
NASCAR pit chicks no more the universe
is just off its axis so where is this
all leading up to honestly I'm not
entirely sure I stopped intellectually
absorbing anything that I said about 15
minutes ago but the prompter is telling
me to say this chuckecheese you have
lost your way and we want to help you
help yourselves you know recently we
discovered that another beloved rodent
is set to enter the public domain in the
US at the end of this year the original
Steamboat Willie Mickey Mouse will soon
be a free agent and I would heavily
recommend that you consider adopting him
he is the perfect fit he's a famous
rodent who loves to entertain and he
won't be afraid to push boundaries
because once he enters the public domain
you can easily turn a sweet lovable
Mouse into a shitalking one I'll show
you just how it could work please come
out here Mickey please come say hi come
say hi to
everyone hey there Mickey hey how you
doing hey W
sh wow where where's Shelly you you
really won't let that go will you Mickey
no they haven't found her yet have they
well no no they haven't that's a solid
Point Mickey in order to restore balance
to the Chuck-E-Cheese Universe we
promise that he will hit you with that
classic hostile crowd work that this
brand was frankly built on top of how
would you say happy birthday to the kids
Mickey you're not special nothing about
you is
special I love it Mickey that is just
coldblooded and instead of singing happy
birthday to your kids when he brings out
the pet he'll say this as a citizen of
the United States you are part of the
most violent genocidal imperialistic
Empire the world has ever known your
silence is
complicity Lord Mickey and if you're
wondering if this one will Jerk it from
inside the costume to that we say oh I'm
doing it right
now and we wouldn't have it any other
way so the offer is on the table
Chuck-E-Cheese this disgusta mouse could
soon be yours that is our show thank you
so much for watching good
night here he is no hey hey Micky don't
Loom don't Loom over me this is sexual
harassment